NARRATOR: Rod Bud is
the safety supervisor,
and is responsible for
bringing these scientists back
home alive.
ROD BUD: Fins on, we're
good to jump in the water.
NARRATOR: He'll be the first
one in, to ensure conditions are
safe for the rest of the team.
[music playing]
Without protective clothing, ice
cold waters can knock a person
unconscious within minutes.
While this team is wearing
well-insulated dry suits,
their heads are almost
completely exposed.
This is just a quick test
dive, but when the real mission
begins, the dive
team will only get
40 minutes to finish the job.
And at 35 minutes,
we give four pulls.
And we're able to
call the diver,
and say, dive's
pretty much over.
NARRATOR: Down here,
ropes signals are
the only way to call for help.
But as the body's core
temperature decreases,
one of the first handicaps
is loss of dexterity.
And at these
temperatures, regulators
can quickly malfunction and
drain the diver's air supply.
[music playing]
[inaudible] slow.
Oh.
Good.
Very well?
OK?
My hands-- my hands
are pretty cold.
It does drop your whole core
temperature there a little bit
though.
NARRATOR: Until his body
temperature returns to normal,
Rod is prohibited
from going back down.